besides the spectacular action one thing
that really distinguished the last Fast
& Furious movie was rapper Wiz Khalifa's
beautiful ballad called see you again
people love that's young you know now I
haven't seen the new movie I was
wondering are they gonna have a song
like that but I'm told it also has a
very powerful anthem in it and we were
lucky enough to get the artists to
perform it here tonight
please welcome singing their song racing
to love from fate of the Furious Ethan
Takahama and Lil juicebox we don't have
this we got family when I get behind the
wheel baby I know you're with me yeah
[Music]
when I slide myself inside you it's like
racing
[Music]
Racing 2 now breaking taboos can't get
in unless you
[Music]
[Music]
damn fool let me break it down slinging
meet up in the tailpipe those were hunk
what to check a Jaguar like the point
stop put some stank up in the muffler
stop it I'm really sorry I had no idea
what that song was about
we'll take plie please Ethan Takahama
and lil juice bustin right
you